new fears vladimir putin is ramping up
his brutality because time is running
out for his military according to
reports russian forces are getting low
on equipment and manpower and may only
be able to fight full strength for 10 to
14 more days despite evidence of war
crimes the white house saying there's no
red line
we don't like red lines around here so
i'm not going to use that phrasing but
um you are obviously correct that what
he has he's been very clear and
consistent about his that he does not
have the intention of sending us troops
to ukraine uh that has not changed
and republican senator tom cotton
calling on biden to actually stand up to
putin
what we should stop doing is worry about
what vladimir putin thinks will be
escalatory quit letting him set the
terms of how we will support ukraine we
should get off the back foot get on the
front foot and make vladimir putin
worried about what will be escalatory
so sandra they don't like red lines what
do you make of that i mean that's that's
basically you know we're not gonna we're
not we're not gonna take a stand or
maybe they're just keeping their cards
close to their vest i you know i again i
think tomorrow will be a big moment
zelinski's going to yeah he's going to
make his his statements very heard
by for us members of congress tomorrow
um
here's what i think as far as the
progression of all of this i think you
go back to ambassador
volker's words that this is a defining
moment in all of this and we have to
start saying what we are going to do
rather than what we will not do and i
listen to jen saki every day judge you
see if you're watching we have a lot of
times we have her briefings and they are
very quick to say what they will not do
and not broadcast what we don't um as
far as lindsey graham earlier today
saying why he believes that the u.s is
not getting involved and president biden
folded like a cheap suit i think was his
exact words on getting involved with the
transfer of those mig jets he says he he
believes putin got in his ear and
threatened escalation if you do and
therefore we are letting putin determine
the next moves of the united states in
this fight and that has to come to an
end
jesse what should we do
senator what's the senator i can't
remember tom cotton yeah thank you
sandra
uh he says we should be setting the
terms what would those terms be i
remember when trump just threatened to
nuke everybody
i didn't want to bring that up but i did
i did look into that today so he
threatened to nuke north korea remember
my button is bigger than yours and my
button works right he threatened to nuke
the iranians uh he said we are the
consequences the likes of which few
throughout history have ever suffered
before and then he told putin that if he
invaded ukraine on his watch he'd nuke
moscow and then he said all options were
on the table in venezuela you know i
like that line all options are on the
table and then he threatened mexico he
was going to designate the cartels as
terror groups that means you can go
drone inside mexico proper now remember
those four years it was it seemed
chaotic but it was relatively stable on
the world stage biden's approach is so
conventional
it's like
he's a nato hawk but a typical liberal
dove it's like your typical
you know washington
business lunch you get you know your
steak and your salad and your
unsweetened iced tea it's obvious that
might not work though so what we're
asking is joe order off the menu maybe a
naval blockade maybe the missile defense
system that i suggested maybe you pay a
visit to his girlfriend in the swiss
alps chalet knock on the door with a
stripper gram i'm just saying get inside
the guy's head do something that he's
not expecting because you have about a
week and a half two and a half weeks
before keeve is surrounded and then you
have no leverage after that
you know uh ralda we were talking in the
green room uh that we keep we keep
hearing
competing narratives the russians are on
the run that's according to uk defense
uh sources but then you look at the map
and the map doesn't look the map doesn't
look good
i think that
this is not about biden this is about
putin putin has utter disregard for
human life he doesn't care he'll send
those troops charging an american
commander will see a an outpost an enemy
strong point and flank it and do all the
russians will keep slamming it slamming
it slamming it until finally if there's
a last russian left belt
this is
an existential crisis right now and that
for us to believe that putin will submit
to the mother of all negotiations that
greg uh keeps promoting i think is
extremely naive with all due respect
he's not gonna what's your solution you
keep saying you don't have my solution
is you have to beat him
you have to beat him if this is a
limited war now it makes no sense to me
not to deliver the mig-29s if if
if this is a limited war it makes no
sense to not take those patriots and get
them into
ukraine yeah get them into you because
the only the only red line right now
is the blood of the ukrainian people
fighting the russians
they are the they are
defending the free world that's the
that's
the front line of humanity civilization
right now that's what it is it is
zielinski and the ukrainians and we have
to give them whatever we can without
putting americans in the cockpit or
behind the buttons of the patriot
missile system i think that you can do
it you can do you stop advertising
everything fight them uh the
the thing about the russians very
quickly they think about the russian
army they're saying now that as evidence
of the russian army falling apart
they're looting uh killing and uh and
terrorizing the that's a weapon
that's a weapon they they they're
looting and they don't have supplies but
they'll loot anyway they'll terrorize
anyway ask the german women who they
feared at the end of world war ii judge
last word
i disagree with heroldo
[Laughter]
geraldo said it's not about biden it's
about putin so the question that i ask
you geraldo is why didn't putin do this
when trump was president
and i don't bring up president trump
that much okay but i tell you right now
that he didn't do it when trump was
president because he knew that donald
trump would come in if you touch one
hair on one innocent civilian he
wouldn't care nato or non-nato and don't
tell me that putin isn't afraid of
someone biden is responsible for the
decline of the west what we are seeing
right now is a
i can't say the word is a wuss
we've got a bully in the in the in the
yard in the playground yard in the
schoolyard and everybody's back at the
fence all right
oh wait wait a minute let me finish
all we have to do is we have enough oil
in canada the united states and mexico
and we could be our own super powers but
right now the biden administration is
not only hurting the americans and all
this hashtag blame putin tick-tock
nonsense
all this is crap all he has to do is
turn to america and let us be the
strength and he is destroying the west
how do you know that putin wasn't
playing trump how do you know
that he was playing trump with trump
i like trump i love you it's not about
loving trump it's about the fact that
trump had everybody against the wall how
do you know that i don't think there was
anything trump would give him afraid
anyway damn what putin thinks i only
care what putin did and he was a
wuss when trump was president and that's
the end of it there you go that might be
my favorite conversation of this whole
year
we're monitoring the latest from ukraine
but in the meantime a suspected serial
killer nabbed after a murder spree in
two liberal cities